A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE MAY
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE THE
HEARING IN PERSON. WE'RE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MASS BE WARNED
IN PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A
MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU.
SB FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
WELCOME HAS BEEN APPROVED FOR
CONSENT SO WE ONLY HAVE ONE
AUTHOR PRESENTING A BELL AND
HOPEFULLY SHE IS ON HER WAY.
ANY PRIMARY WITNESS TESTIMONY
SHOULD BE LIMITED TO TWO
MINUTES AND SUPPORT IN TWO
MINUTES IN OPPOSITION.
REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE TESTIFYING.
WITNESSES MAY TESTIFY BY PHONE
OR IN PERSON. IF ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. THE CALL IN NUMBER
FOR THE HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU ARE CALLING IN POLICE PLAN
TO DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR PRESENTATION.
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN QUEUE. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS THAT WE ALL FACE HERE
IN THE CAPITAL. AND WITH THAT
WE ARE GOING TO- ASK. THE CLERK
TO HELP ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
WITH APRIL HASN'T KILEY. OKAY
BENNETT CORREA. CHECK OUT.
CUNNINGHAM THERE GALLAGHER.
IRWIN YEAH WICKS. WAIT HAVE A
CAR THANK YOU AND WITH THAT WE
CAN TURN TODAY TO THE BILL
BEFORE US SB THIRTY NINE
WELCOME SENATOR GROWTH. IS IT.
SORRY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
MY BILL TODAY I'VE ACCEPTED THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT WILL
LIMIT THE SHARING OF SO
SECURITY INFORMATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND I'VE
ALSO LIKE TO THINK THAT YOU'RE
IN A STEP FOR WORKING THEN WE
WITH ME ON THIS BILL SB THIRTY
NINE AIMS TO ADOPT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROTECT
TAXPAYER FUNDS WELL HELPING TO
ENSURE THAT UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS ONLY GO TO ELIGIBLE
EMPLOYED UNEMPLOYED INDIVIDUALS
BY MANDATING THAT THE EDT
CONDUCT REGULAR CROSS MATCHING
OF THEIR RECORDS. WITH DATA
PROVIDED RECEIPT BY CDC ARE AT
LEAST EVERY NINETY DAYS AND
REQUIRES THE DATA ONLY INCLUDE
CURRENT INFORMATION ON CURRENT
INMATES OVER THE LAST YEAR
EVERYONE OF OUR OFFICES HAS
RECEIVED THOUSANDS OF CALLS
FROM CONSTITUENTS ASKING FOR
HELP TO REVIVE REESE IN
RECEIVING THEIR BENEFITS- THAT
THEY GET FROM EDIE D. THAT THEY
RIGHTFULLY DESERVE WELL SINGLE
MOTHERS AND FATHERS WERE FORCED
TO DRAIN THEIR SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
TO CAREFOR FAMILIES TO PUT
FOOD ON THEIR TABLES FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS REWARDED TO PEOPLE THEY
DID NOT DESERVE THEM. FOLLOWING
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
RESPONSE TO COVERT NINETEEN- IN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA
TASK THE EDT WITH DISTRIBUTING
CARES ACT. FRIENDS THAT.
THROUGH THE NEWLY TO PANDA AND
AS- PROGRAM HOWEVER DESPITE
HAVING BEEN WARNED BY THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL RISK OF FRAUD. THE
EDT WAS NOT PREPARED TO PREVENT
AND ADDRESS THE FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS FILED WITH THIS
DEPARTMENT. TO MAKE MATTERS
WORSE A STATE AUDIT REVEALED
THAT EDT WAS TOLD ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL PROBLEM BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN WAS STILL
NOT PREPARED. IN ADDITION AT
THE TIME OF THE FRAUD WAS
DISCOVERED CALIFORNIA IN
CALIFORNIA THIRTY FIVE OTHER
STATES HAD ALREADY IMPLEMENTED
SOME FORM OF FRAUD PREVENTION
TO ADDRESS INMATE SCAMS. THE
FRAUD WAS SO PROLIFIC THAT EDT
IS PUT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS HAS
PAID OUT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS SOME ESTIMATE
THE TOTAL FRAUD WILL SUPPRESS
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS. JUST
THIS PAST WEEK IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PRISON INMATE WAS
INDICTED ON FEDERAL CHARGES FOR
A ONE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLAR
FRAUDULENT UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. SCAM OF WHICH OURS
CALIFORNIA STATE ET DE OFFICE
PAID OUT NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. IT'S THIS IS TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE FITTING THE BILL THAT
WILL GET STUCK WITH THIS BILL
IF THIS ISSUE ISN'T ADDRESSED
IN THE U. I TRUST FUND
CONTINUES TO GROW. SB THIRTY
NINE IS A BIPARTISAN MEASURE
AND HAS RECEIVE NO- NO VOTES
AND DISTRICT IS JUST FOLLOWING
THE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS
TO MAKE SURE THAT CROSS
MATCHING. IS DONE SO THAT WE
PROTECT THOSE THAT- NEED THE
BENEFITS AND THE DESERVE THE
BENEFITS BUT THE INMATE CAN'T
SCAMS WOULD STOP- JOINING ME ON
THE PHONE I HOPE IS A KERN
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY. AS
CYNTHIA ZIMMER WHO WILL SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY NINE-
WE TOLD HER THAT THE COMMITTEE
WOULD SEE THE BILL AT ELEVEN SO
SHE MAY OR MAY NOT BE ON THIS.
PHONE MISTER CHAIR I APOLOGIZE.
THANKS UNDER OF COURSE WE HAVE
A- IN THIS. AND LET'S JUST GO
AHEAD AND CHECK WITH OUR
OPERATOR AND SEE IF WE HAVE A
CYNTHIA SOMMER FROM THE KERN
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE WITH US. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I DO NOT AS OF
THIS TIME MR CHER SHOW HER ON
THE LINE- I WILL PROMPT HER IF
SHE WISHES. AS SHE MAY HAVE
DIALED IN AS AN ATTENDEE RATHER
THAN A CO HOST. TO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO TO PUT YOURSELF INTO
Q. WELL WE'RE WAITING FOR THAT
I. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. C. NONE I
WILL GO BACK TO OUR OPERATOR TO
WE HAVE EITHER A THEIR PRIMARY
WITNESS OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES-
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME SIR. OKAY THANK YOU THEN
AT THIS POINT I THINK WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND TURN TO OUR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND WE
HAVE BECCA CREAMER MOTOR FROM
THE ACLU. ARE THEY ON THE LINE.
THEY ARE THEY ARE OPEN LINE AT
THIS TIME. SACRAMENTO I'M-
CALLING IT A BEHALF OF THE EAST
HOW ACTION ON OF THE AND AT THE.
NINE WELL WE SHARE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE SOLUTION PROPOSED BY
ASK THIRTY IN CAP TO THAT BUT
WILL HARM IN. PEOPLE THEIR
FAMILIES. FIRST OF ALL AND
PARKS P. WE'RE NOT THE- AND
EVERY ET FIVE. NOT ONLY
INCARCERATED P. HAVE THEIR AND
FROM YOU I FORGOT BUT OUT THERE
CAN. BUT FORMERLY AN ARCHER
PEOPLE HAVE REFER IN THE TERM
BUT THE. THANK I EDT ACCESS TO
ENCOURAGE RATED PEOPLE THAN
FROM FOR THE PURPOSES OF ALL
AND I'M QUITE BENEFITS ISN'T
OVER BROAD TO ADDRESS PROBLEM.
THURSDAY ARE CONCERNED THAT THE
UP LAWS CLAIM FOR I'M AND TO
THE COLD MILD BUT THING NET
RESOURCE FORMER AND- IN. WHO
ALREADY THAT WERE THE LABOR MY-
RECORDKEEPING AND THE LADY IN
THE REAL SAID AND HER. IN COME
UP THAT RECORD SYSTEM ONLY
EXACT ARKAN BANK THE ATHLETES
NINE WILL LEAD TO LONG THAT. ON
EMPTY BENEFITS. ACCORDING TO
STANFORD I'M NOT ASPECT
AMERICAN SIXTY PERSON OF RECORD
AND I THINK BILL THAT AND FROM.
THAT MEANS THAT SOMEONE REALLY
I'M NOT REAL. THAT EVER THE
WRONG PERSON FOR EXAMPLE HAD
BEEN BEATEN BY AND BAN UNDER SB
NINE. SAID IN OF OUR GOLDMAN
ARE. YOU CANNOT BENEFIT TO
WHICH THEY ARE LAWFULLY
ENTITLED THIRTY THREE THEN WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB THIRTY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M GONNA SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEE NON WE WILL GO BACK
TO THE PHONE LINEMR PRATER DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ON THE
PHONE TO. WELL WE DO WE HAVE
ONE LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN LINE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER REMEMBERS TO MORNINGS
PAUL YOU ARE ACTUALLY-
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS KERN COUNTY INNER
DRIVE BOTH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THE MISSED
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE
TO WE HAVE THE- PRIMARY WITNESS
OR ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE
LINES. WELL WE HAVE ONE THAT IS
JUST QUEUING UP PLEASE ALLOW
SALUTE MOMENT TO GIVE THEM
THEIR LINE NUMBER. AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
GOOD MORNING SURE NUMBERS THAT
WE ARE ACTUALLY ALSO IN
SUPPORT- THIS IS MICHELLE
THOMAS SHOCKS REPRESENTING THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND ANYONE ELSE ON
THE PHONE LINES. THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AT THIS POINT
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO-
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT SEEING
DONALD RIGHT- BUT YOU SENATOR
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS JUST
A COUPLE OF COMMENTS MADE BY
THE OPPOSITION WHEN THE BILL
FIRST STARTED IN THE AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKING IT DID INCLUDE
COUNTY JAILS WHERE PEOPLE WERE
ARRESTED AND HELD- WE
ELIMINATED THAT PROVISION IN
THE BILL AND IT NOW ONLY DEALS
WITH C. D. C. R. C. WOULD HAVE
TO BE ACTUALLY- PUT. INTO THE
M. INCARCERATED OUR PRISON
SYSTEM IN ORDER TO HAVE YOUR
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER I SHARED
AND CROSS MATCHED WITH- EDT
THAT IS CURRENTLY TAKING PLACE
NOW IT'S NOT IN STATUTE. AND IT
IS JUST AN INDEPENDENT AUDITOR-
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE FOLLOW
TO ADDRESS THE FRIED SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER AND
I WANNA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THE SPELLING FOR
WORKING WITH OUR COMMITTEE ON
THE AMENDMENTS AND- YEAH I
THINK YOU'VE HEARD- AS YOU
KNOW- BIPARTISAN. CONCERN ABOUT
THE ISSUES WITH FRIDAY EDT
ABOUT A LOT OF. A LOT OF
CONCERNS ABOUT EIGHTY DE I
GUESS WOULD BE THAT THE MILD
WAY TO PUT IT. AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR APPROACH HERE
AND ALSO APPRECIATE YOU I'M
WORKING ON THE AMENDMENTS
BECAUSE WE DON'T INADVERTENTLY
WANT TO CREATE- ONE PROBLEM IS
WE'RE TRYING TO FIX ANOTHER AND
WE HEARD FROM. THE FOLKS AT DOJ
THAT THERE WAS INFORMATION THAT
THEY DID NOT NEED- AND I
APPRECIATE YOU- YOU KNOW
CONSIDERING THAT AND- AND
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT WHETHER CDC ARE. NEEDS
INMATES SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
THAT WILL BE TRANSMITTED TO
THEM FROM EDT TO COMBAT FRAUD.
A PARTICULAR WHEN THEY'RE
ALREADY IN THE POSSESSION OF
THOSE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
SO. WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO
DENY. ANYONE NECESSARY TOOLS IN
INVESTIGATING FRAUD- THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY AN URGENT ISSUE AND
YOU KNOW EVERY DOLLAR THAT GOES
OUT THAT- THAT IN IN A
FRAUDULENT CLAIM IS A DOLLAR
THAT WE TAKE AWAY FROM HOUSING
FROM EDUCATION FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION FROM
SOCIAL SERVICES FROM. SO MANY
OTHERPRIORITIES- AND SO WE
WANT TO BE REALLY- YOU KNOW
VIGOROUS IN IN COMBAT ABOUT BUT
ALSO DO IT IN A SMART AND
THOUGHTFUL. WAY THAT PAYS
ATTENTION TO THE DETAILS HERE
AND THAT PROTECTS THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION OF. OF CALIFORNIANS
AND DOESN'T NEED THE SLEE-
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL FRAUD BUT
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE
TAKEN TODAY I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL- PARTICULAR
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT THE CDC ARE ISSUE- AND
WITH THAT. THE WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE SO. MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
INSURANCE COMMITTEE. GABRIEL HI
GABRIEL I KILEY. KILEY I PARA
QUE HAN PARA QUE HAN I'VE DONE
IT SENATE I COREA COREA I CHAO
CHAO I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
AYE GALLAGHER GALLAGHER I IRWIN
IRWIN AYE WICKES WICKES HI
THANK YOU THAT BILL PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER
GRADUATIONS YOUR BILL IS OUT
AND- WE ALSO HAVE ONE BUILT ON
CONSENT THIS IS- FROM SENATOR
WELCOME SORRY BE WILLING TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. MR SHARKEY
MISTER CAR CAN CALL THE ROLL.
YEAH THE MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO INSURANCE COMMITTEE GABRIEL
HI GABRIEL I KILEY KILEY I'VE
R. K. R. K. HAND I'VE BEEN AT.
SENATE I. I CHAO CHAO AYE
CUNNINGHAM I CUNNINGHAM I
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER I. IRWIN.
HI CAROLYN I WICKS WHICH WAY AT
CONSENT CALENDAR PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY. GREAT AND WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE THAT NEEDS TO
ALLOCATE THESE. WE'RE GOOD.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WITH THAT I WANT
TO HANK ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THIS. QUICK
HEARING- I DID ALSO WANT TO
JUST TAKE A MOMENT. AND
RECOGNIZE AND ACKNOWLEDGE OUR
TERROR MERIDA SAID ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAD OUR NEW. ASSISTANT
MAJORITY LEADER FOR HIS VERY
THOUGHTFUL LEADERSHIP OF THIS
COMMITTEE OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS FROM YOU KNOW WITH THIS
COMMITTEE HAS PASSED A LANDMARK
LEGISLATION UNDER YOUR
LEADERSHIP. AND WE'RE SO
PLEASED AND GRATEFUL TO
CONTINUE HAVING YOU SERVE ON
THE COMMITTEE A TO BENEFIT FROM
YOUR WISDOM AND GUIDANCE I DID
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE IN THE SPACE WHICH
HAS. YOU YOU'RE QUITE A LEGACY
SO THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE- AND WITH
THAT. I WILL. DURING THE
HEARING.